>> Brett: AT THE IDEOLOGICAL
DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE ON FULL
DISPLAY TONIGHT.
LAST NIGHT DURING THE CANDIDATE
DEBATE IF YOU EXPECTED ATTACKS
ON SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY WON
THE PRESIDENCY, YOU WERE NOT
DISAPPOINTED.
YOU PROBABLY DID NOT PREDICT WHO
THAT WOULD BE.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
THE SURPRISING ANSWER TONIGHT
FROM DETROIT.
>> FORGET HOPE AND CHANGE, MOST
CANDIDATES ARE HOPING FOR A
CHANGE.
FROM THE WAY PRESIDENT OBAMA
GOVERNED.
>> I WAS SURPRISED ABOUT HOW
MUCH INCOMING THERE WAS ABOUT
BARACK.
>> DAY SPENT THE DEBATE ON THE
LEGACY OF BARACK OBAMA.
>> I'VE LEARNED THE LESSONS OF
THE PAST AND THE VICE PRESIDENT
HASN'T.
>> YOU INVOKE PRESIDENT OBAMA
MORE THAN ANYBODY IN THIS
CAMPAIGN COME YOU CAN'T DO IT
WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT AND DODGE
IT WHEN IT'S NOT.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS
ATTACKED TOO FOR DETAINING
MIGRANT CHILDREN.
>> THEY ARE CHILDREN.
>> HARRIS LATER HIT BIDEN
BECAUSE SHE THINKS HE LEAVES
MILLIONS UNINSURED WITH A POLICY
MODELED ON OBAMACARE.
AT >> FOR A DEMOCRAT TO BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT FOR A PLAN
THAT DOES NOT COVER EVERYONE I
THINK IS WITHOUT EXCUSE.
>> BIDEN SHOT BACK MEDICARE FOR
ALL COSTS TRILLIONS TOO MUCH.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
IF >> WON CRIMINAL JUSTICE CAME
UP, CORY BOOKER COINED A PHRASE
THAT SUMS UP HIS FRUSTRATION.
>> YOU'RE DIPPING IN THE
KOOL-AID AND YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE FLAVOR.
>> KAMALA HARRIS STOOD OUT AND
TULSI GABBARD STUDIED HER
RESUME.
>> 1500 PEOPLE FOR MARIJUANA
VIOLATIONS AND LAUGHED ABOUT IT
WHEN SHE WAS ASKED IF SHE SMOKED
MARIJUANA.
>> NOT ALL WENT TO JAIL UNDER
ATTORNEY GENERAL HARRIS WERE
PROSECUTED BY HER, NOW SHE IS
SHRUGGING OFF ATTACKS BY A
CONGRESSWOMAN WHO ONCE VISITED
SYRIAN DICTATOR BASHAR AL-ASSAD.
>> I TAKE THOSE ATTACKS ONLY
WITH SO MUCH SERIOUSNESS.
>> DID JOE BIDEN PROTECT HIS
LEAD?
HE'S CONFIDENT IN HIS
PERFORMANCE BUT HE ADMITS HIS
CLOSING COULD'VE BEEN BETTER.
>> THAT WAS NOT AN ANNOUNCEMENT
OF A CAMPAIGN IN 3030 OR AN ATM
NUMBER.
>> I SHOULD'VE SAID TEXT.
>> IT'S A CURIOUS CALCULATION
CANDIDATES MADE TO ATTACK
BARACK OBAMA'S LEGACY.